thank you so just for getting started
here is there anyone who hasn't heard of
webassembly
or azzam alright great awesome is there
anyone here who's actually had a reason
to use webassembly in a production app
okay alright so we're all about on the
same page I'd like to invite you back in
a journey of time to the year 2017 like
most of you I had heard about
webassembly but beyond some surface
level stuff I didn't actually know very
much about it I read this headline and I
thought huh well I mean I guess if
webassembly really does kill JavaScript
then I'll figure that stuff out but it
sure seems like people have wanted
JavaScript to die for a while now and
we're all still here and besides what
does a typical JSF need was him for
anyway
well little did I know my experience was
about to take a turn for the atypical I
work for a consulting firm based here in
Seattle called genui we're in Fremont
and we do a lot of different kinds of
work but I think our dev manager
described it best when he said our web
expertise is really in doing stuff
that's a little weird last year we had
one of those weird client requests and
I'd like to tell you the story about how
and why we built a screen recording and
video editing app for Chrome OS that
runs entirely client-side our
requirements were as follows the app was
meant to look and feel like it was
native to Chrome OS and act as a
competitor to other Chrome OS screen
recording apps out there the client
specifically requested that the app
would provide video editing capability
and it needed to run locally offline
there are a couple of ways to develop
for Chrome OS and we decided to use
chrome packaged apps on Chrome OS
packaged apps are essentially just web
apps that are given some additional
hardware related api's at their core
they're just JavaScript HTML and CSS as
we started to investigate how we wanted
to implement the project it was actually
surprised to discover just how much it's
possible to do with media and they did
javascript for instance if the user can
sense you can capture their whole screen
or their webcam and then use the native
native recorder api to record that
screen create a video and allow the user
to download it to their machine and
that's possible in any web browser or
any modern web browser there's nothing
special about Chromebook that lets you
do it so if all we needed was a screen
recording app then we'd be set with
those tools but the client had requested
some video editing capabilities and as a
result we started to get into a realm of
things that are technically possible in
JavaScript but just not a great idea for
a variety of reasons for instance if you
wanted to create a watermark you can
create a media stream that collects data
from a canvas element you can then draw
your watermark onto every frame of that
water canvas element and then merge it
into the stream from your screen
recording but unsurprisingly it's to
memory intensive so the resulting videos
were kind of like watching a very badly
dubbed foreign film you've got all the
pieces there but they don't line up
another of the video editing features we
wanted to implement was trimming or
shortening the video it turns out you
can actually do that in plain JavaScript
so long as you only want to trim the end
of the video do you want to trim the
beginning you're out of luck at least in
Chrome and that brings us to
functionality that simply isn't possible
in native JavaScript once you create
that WebM file from your media recorder
you're done there's no way to add a
watermark or a filter or something else
after the fact it's also not possible to
re-encode the video the media recorder
API will give you a WebM so if you
wanted a gif or an mp4 then you can't do
it with native functionality at this
point we went back to the client and we
recommended a server-side only solution
and there were two big reasons for this
the first is that video editing is a
memory intensive process and Chromebooks
are not powerful
machines by design they are meant to do
most of their work from the clown and
the second is that really client-side
video editing pushes the limit of what's
even possible on the web today we had
two people working on this project we
did not have an infinite budget and we
wanted to deliver something reasonable
the client did take our recommendation
into account but ultimately asked us to
move ahead with a client side only
implementation this set us off on a
journey to discover the limits of what's
actually possible on the web today since
we had already determined that video
editing isn't possible in native
JavaScript we needed to find a way to
run code that is not native javascript
in the browser and web assembly is by no
means the first tool that allows you to
do this in fact running non J's code in
the browser has a long history
does anyone here remember a little thing
obscure called flash anyone any
ActionScript devs out there
what about Silverlight
I gave away my best joke alright you may
have heard that webassembly
isn't just another way to write plugins
and that's true but without
understanding a little more about
plugins in general it's hard to know why
the comparison is even being made so the
90s are in again let's go back to 1995
we are all wearing janko's and the
slater standing in front of you isn't me
but this guy because you're living on
the cutting edge your browser of choice
is obviously Netscape and Netscape has
just released the Netscape plug-in API
or NPAPI NPAPI is the first way to
develop plug-ins or browser extensions
and to handle media from within the
browser what happened was the browser
would come across content that it
couldn't handle and detect the file type
and then load the appropriate plug-in
that plug-in would run in place on your
web page as of today NPAPI is deprecated
in every major browser and that's mostly
due to issues with complexity and
security it's also because the advent of
html5 means that the browser can handle
a lot of kinds of kind of things
natively that would otherwise have been
handled by plugins but plugins didn't
actually fully die with NPAPI in 2009
Google released the pepper plug-in API
or ppapi
pepper is a build chain that produces
binary file types called Native Client
and portable Native Client or NaCl and
pnacl get it salt and pepper
portable Native Client was meant to
provide a more secure less complex
alternative to NPAPI with it
developers could recompile libraries
written in C or C++ to a portable Native
Client format and then that could be run
from within the browser and accessed in
JavaScript for those web assembly fans
in the crowd some of that may sound
familiar so why aren't we all talking
about pepper and how it hearkens the
death of the most widely used
programming language in the world today
well an open standard for pepper was
never created the resulting portable
Native Client files were only ever
supported on Chrome chromium ambling
based browsers as of today portable
Native Client is deprecated for every
platform except Chromebook but then of
course we were building for Chromebooks
so let's put a pin in that that brings
us to today and webassembly like
portable Native Client webassembly
takes advantage of common hardware
capabilities to deliver native or near
native performance the EM script and
build chain allows developers to convert
libraries written not only in C or C++
but also rust into a wasm format that
runs from within the browser developers
can even write directly in web assembly
for all you super nerds out there who
just can't get enough of assembly
language unlike pepper web assembly is
an open standard and it's been adopted
by every modern browser so it's really
something that you can use and deliver
to the vast majority of the web but that
doesn't actually say so much about
what's great about web assembly in the
first place or why we'd want to use C or
C++ they're really a couple of reasons
why you might use web assembly in your
application the first of these is
performance performance on web assembly
in general is much faster than native
JavaScript and that's mostly due to a
lack of dynamic typing and web assembly
of course if you're interested there are
many many other talks that you can look
into on the subject and I strongly
recommend Lynn Clark's cartoon
introduction to web assembly or for that
matter any of lenss talks due to
performance considerations you might
look into a web assembly if you have a
particularly heavy operation that you
could perform in JavaScript but you
would prefer not to for instance
every single page web application
framework that most of us in this room
use has some kind of a Dom dipping
operation it's a heavy thing to do and
it can have negative performance
implications for updating your page
particularly in component heavy
scenarios glimmer which is the Dom
rendering engine by the Ember team has
an existing build that leverages web
assembly for this purpose and that is a
methodology that should ultimately rely
so in a much faster rendering engine and
I'm definitely not just saying that
because you Hooda Katz who is the
primary architect of glimmer is speaking
later today there are folks who are
looking into this for react as well
performance aside the second reason you
might want to use Waze 'm speaks to our
problem with video editing as we
discussed earlier you can't really edit
video in JavaScript but you absolutely
can edit video in C++ in fact you can do
several things in C++ or rust that are
outside the current capabilities of
modern browsers that includes not just
video editing but also audio editing
platform emulation and a number of
different kinds of games
well Haslam was literally built for our
use case and so now we just needed to
choose a video editing library that we
could use it was important to find a
library because as I mentioned earlier
there were only two of us and we had
neither the budget nor the expertise to
build something by ourselves from
scratch it turns out there aren't
actually tons of video editing options
in either C++ or rust and that may be
due in part to the tremendous popularity
of ffmpeg which is an open source
multimedia library written in C++ ffmpeg
is a command-line tool that supports
adding watermarks or trimming or
cropping video or just about any other
kind of thing that you might want to do
with it our early research indicated
that ffmpeg could be used through either
portable Native Client or webassembly
and ultimately we were unable to find
another good candidate naturally it's
chess devs the first thing we did was go
to the NPM registry and actually there
is an ffmpeg j/s so let's take a look at
that github page this looks pretty good
right and actually I am hugely grateful
to get hub user
who's the author of this package and
also a picture Romanov who forked it and
added some extra documentation without
these folks we really would have been
lost but these were enough bread comes
for us to sort of figure out how to do
this but getting back to my NPM install
I saw a couple of concerning things
right off the bat first is the size the
entirety of ffmpeg even when compiled is
about 15 megabytes that is way too much
to load when we're loading the app and
it is a lot to ask users to download
from the chrome store to begin one the
default build also includes tons of
functionality we didn't plan on using it
also includes the h.264 codec which as
of last year was still patented we
needed a binary that was compiled
without it and second the version of
ffmpeg that this library is based on is
an old one this is like a couple of
years old so we came to the conclusion
that even though there is an existing
NPM install for this library we still
needed to compile our own wasm file this
is the point at which we started to get
into technologies that Jas devs don't
tend to use on a day to day basis and
the first of these is called M script in
M script in is a build chain SDK just
like pepper and for those of you who
haven't done a lot of this kind of thing
it's vaguely analogous to a tool like
Babel M script in is a command line tool
that takes unn compiled c++ library and
builds it in such a way that awasum is
produced you can pass in various build
options when you use it so if for
instance you wanted to build your wesson
binary in such a way that it's
compatible with web workers you would do
that as a part of your overall m script
and build command so that's that's a lot
of high-level information let's bring it
down and take a look at something
concrete the following example is a
little hello world written in c like
most of you I don't really program in C
on a day-to-day basis or ever but we can
look at what's here and determine what
it does easily enough the main method is
what's runs when the app loads we've
imported the standard input/output
library and then just used it to print
our hello world in a C application this
would print to your console and actually
in our app will print to the JavaScript
console too but will also display it
in the Dom now we need to compile our
hello world to a wasm file you can do
that in M script in by using the
following command you can see here that
we do need to specify wasm and that's
because Emscripten can compile to other
formats - such as a s MJS also - o
output 'html let's M script a note that
I actually want Emscripten to build my
webpage for me rather than just compile
a binary so let's take a look at that
web page as you can see there's a lot
more going on here than just hello world
by default M script ins output gives you
a page with a console that you can use
to see the wasm output in order to do
this it also generates some JavaScript
glue code to connect the HTML with
awasum binary so that seems simple
enough right but if this were say a
Thanksgiving in Turkey drawing tutorial
then we're at about this step here we've
drawn an outline of our hand and you all
know what comes next
right
we don't need HelloWorld
we need ffmpeg and there are more than a
few steps in between but you know like
every now and again things just kind of
work the way you think they should so
it's worth just trying to convert ffmpeg
and see what happens next
first we'll go over a couple of terms
you may not be familiar with make is a
UNIX tool that acts as a task runner
just like go up in the JSE Co system
clang is a front-end interface for
compilation tools and GCC is the GNU
UNIX compiler these all work together to
create executables for many C or C++
libraries including ffmpeg to get
started we need to pull ffmpeg down from
github it's open source so everything's
there this is the root folder of the
ffmpeg library what we need to do is use
the project's make file and have all of
those constructions in substitute clang
and GCC with our own M script in Bill
chain piece of cake right in case you
really did think it was cake please
allow me to assure you that it is not to
help you out M scripting has actually
built their own tool that comes with
their bill chain and to help you
substitute M scripting for GCC and clang
and C projects
it's called M configure so first we call
M configure configure and that will
substitute M script in for GCC and clang
next we'll run and make make and that
should use our hem script infilling for
actually building the library into LLVM
format bit code assuming everything has
gone well this is the point at which we
can run a command that's similar to our
hello world command from earlier but of
course everything has not gone well
after about 20 minutes of compilation
and Makemake has run an error and it
appears to generate from deep within the
heart of this massive library anyone
who's struggled to get their builds to
transpile correctly using webpack or
babel knows the pain that can accompany
production builds particularly as they
become more complex building a project
and c really is no different and
compiling that project into a format for
which it was never in
intended as an even greater degree of
complexity when we're looking at
something like our hello world see from
earlier it seems reasonable to debug the
compilation project the process even
though we're not actually see deaths it
did not seem reasonable to debug this
giant make file and delve into the heart
of the legacy media framework so let's
make a long story short
mmm configure makes a number of
assumptions about your see based build
environment that may or may not be true
for this particular make file it was
necessary to go in and replace every
reference to the existing build chain
with M script n' second Emscripten can't
use anything that uses a SM not a SM j/s
but just a SM and that's used in many C
libraries to provide compiler
instructions to GCC since we're not
actually building with GCC we need to
pass the option to build ffmpeg without
a SM finally Emscripten won't actually
convert every possible combination of
things that can be written in C we had
to patch ffmpeg in a couple of places
just to get the conversion to work at
all in the end however we did prevail so
let's take a look at a demo here we're
looking at a video that has been created
in native JavaScript through a screen
recording of a YouTube clip our media
recorder has returned a blob that we can
convert to a file and then save to the
user's local machine but you'll notice
that we can't seek through this video
and that's not a great user experience
this is due to a chrome specific bug
where their media recorder doesn't
create keyframes as it records therefore
the kind of file that's created doesn't
know important things about itself like
how long it is next you'll recall that
the client wanted to add trim
functionality to our app and that makes
total sense from a user's perspective
we've all started screen recordings
where we forgot to set up our screen and
needed to trim out the first little bit
this is where ffmpeg comes in handy when
we robot WebM video through ffmpeg it'll
add those missing key frames by default
we'll also asked ffmpeg to trim our
video to its desired length when we're
sending it to web assembly it looks a
little like this I've compiled my ffmpeg
build
so that it works with web workers and
then I'll create a new web worker I will
listen to make sure that worker is ready
and once everything is loaded I'll post
a message that contains all the
information that ffmpeg needs to kick
off a trim operation we can see that's a
type of thing that I want to run is
called run and that's the default or
main method in ffmpeg and I've passed in
some data which is actually as a array
buffer finally I pass in the same
arguments that I would pass in if I were
using ffmpeg from the command line so
we've got a - SS that's where you're
starting your video - T that's how long
your video will be and then - C copy
just means we want to use the existing
codec let's see what that looks like
when it's applied to our video all right
so I've kicked off the ffmpeg process by
default in the background and we can see
that before too long we get a little
video it's obviously different than it
was before it's only two seconds long so
that being said there are some important
caveats for using this technology the
last video editing feature requested by
our client was to provide crop and
that's in case the user wants to only
display a portion of what they've
created in their video and you can see
it we've we've kicked off our operation
we're getting lots of logging output
from ffmpeg that's great we know that
something is happening but you know like
I mean it's only that video is only a
minute long and we're still watching it
convert so we obviously can't put that
in front of a user what's up the other
operations were really fast and I told
you earlier that performance and web
assembly is supposed to be much better
right well there are two things
happening here that cause performance
issues and one is just that Riaan coding
takes a little more time than costing
copying the existing codec this
operation would be a little slower from
the command line as well but not by a
factor of about a thousand which is what
we have here it turns out that when
Emscripten performs its conversion there
are a few patterns in
Plus Plus that will convert but have
tremendously negative performance
implications for instance code that
relies on x86 lineman behavior or code
that makes use of set jump to save the
execution context and yes I had to look
that stuff up so in theory could we
address these performance issues and
patch them in the same way we patched
the code that was causing conversion
problems or maybe we could add in web
assembly specific compilation
optimizations to compensate for
compiling without ASM the truth is I
don't really know we did not have the
budget to become all unknowing video
encoding plasm converting masters and
who does really it's also worth
mentioning that winweb assembly shipped
to all major browsers it shipped as an
MVP there's a ton of functionality
coming down the pipeline that might help
to support some of the issues we had
with ffmpeg one of these is
multi-threaded support which would
almost certainly make the re-encoding
process faster wasm is also looking to
support garbage collection which will
open the door to converting languages
well beyond just C++ and rust ultimately
since we were on the Chromebook platform
we took a look at using the pepper build
chain in portable Native Client an
ffmpeg conversion process is already
well defined there and the result is
quite a bit faster than our webassembly
binary although perhaps unsurprisingly
the more performance heavy conversions
still take some time and still produce
an unacceptable user experience on
Chromebooks
due to their lightweight processors so
is this a story about why you shouldn't
use webassembly
not at all we learned a lot and I wanted
to share those takeaways with you first
ffmpeg was almost certainly the wrong
library to start learning about web
assembly and C++ in the first place
there are several existing was important
you can find them on github
next if you're evaluating a new C++
library that you think you'd like to use
then there are some well-known patterns
you can check for to give you a good
idea about whether you should proceed
portability guidelines and API
limitations can be found on the
Emscripten website and this is a case
where it's a good idea to have someone
with some C++ expertise
to help you determine whether your
library of choice contains those
patterns and how difficult it might be
to patch them finally the rest language
was specifically designed with the web
in mind and it looks to support wasum as
a first-class compilation target if the
functionality you're looking for exists
in both C++ and rust it's probably
worthwhile to start with rust web
assembly is an exciting new tool that
opens a new world of functionality and
performance and it's helping to pave the
way to using the browser is a true
application platform but for the average
jst converting functionality into web
assembly is still a pretty big ask it's
tremendously helpful to have access to
expertise in both the source code
getting converted as well as the
intended use of that functionality as
one becomes more mainstream I expect to
see better tooling more libraries and
simpler processes become more prevalent
in the meantime we may all be consuming
web assembly through frameworks long
before we ever have a reason to create
anything ourselves thank you